We're outside the CBS broadcast center
on 57th street and in the middle of a very special
Dear Drew featuring none other than
the goddess legend herself, Martha Stewart
and her man truck.
(audience applause)
It's so cute, right?
I mean, every detail in that truck
we've had multiple pictures taken,
we're gonna share them all with you.
Because details matter.
All right, we're gonna get to our next letter.
Edward from Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania wrote...
A-ha.
It's football season and I love tailgating.
What's your best advice
to throw the best tailgating party?
Edward, Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
Well, I'm gonna hand this one right over to you
because I can't think of a better person
to answer this question.
Well, if you're going to tailgate at a stadium or
in your backyard with a big outdoor TV,
just think of unique things.
You can have a table outside your station wagon or your SUV.
And bring delicious food.
It's the most important thing of a tailgate party
is the food.
You can bring in this enamel cast iron,
this is a Martha pot.
It's so gorgeous.
Isn't that beautiful?
The color.
And inside is this
green chili.
Green Thai chili, I love it so much.
Look at this.
You want a taste?
Yes!
Okay, give me that little bowl.
Use country kinda stuff or this kind of
beautiful -
Oh, look that is so good.
Sour cream, cheddar,
a little bit of lime.
Always have delicious snacks.
Our most popular snacks are the pigs in the blanket
and they come from Martha Stewart Kitchen
which is now in many, many, many grocery stores.
Thousands of grocery stores
in the freezer department.
Can I give you a compliment
'cause I've been dying to tell you this.
I think
that your food is so beautifully packaged.
Yes.
It is so delicious.
It's convenient, it's everywhere.
And
I just really wanna commend you for helping feed people
in an accessible, healthy way.
Thank you.
Your new food line is something I'm the biggest fan of.
That was voted the best frozen cake
in the United States last year.
Isn't that amazing?
Oh my god.
Those are good too.
And, do nice things for your guests.
Look at these.
These were just - we just made these.
They're called lapkins.
So just take yardage and
make a big, big napkin.
So that you don't get dirty when you're sitting outside
on the park bench or on a chair in the parking lot
of the stadium, right?
And we have in the buffet we have chicken wings, of course.
Buffalo chicken wings.
We have fried chicken, we have queso
with the beautiful chips.
And beer, root beer, and wine, whatever.
It's a lot of fun
and if you have a collection of old blankets
that you can sit on,
or wrap yourself in if it's a windy day at the stadium.
Bring those in your SUV or in your station wagon.
I mean, this has been
meaningful.
Mm, good.
Fun.
Oh, really good.
I've been just not stopping over here.
And if you need any advice, help,
or maybe wanna see us try something,
send in your mail.
Questions, requests, photos.
Heartfelt or funny stories.
To find out more,
go to TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com/DearDrew.
I can't wait to read more of your letters on this show.
And
I wanna thank Rachel, Jasmine, Dolores, and Edward
for your letters.
I can't believe I'm about to end this segment this way
'cause it's like my fantasy's coming true.
Truly yours,
Drew and Martha.
Aww, thank you.
(audience applause)